et en année à dix suicides de policiers
depuis le 1er janvier dès lors il pu
aborder ce sujet notre blog de ne jamais
conserver sg le fig 2 volets sont les
organisations syndicales ne m'ont pas
soutenu par exemple lorsque moi je me
demandais ça m'a été refusé par la
majorité ce que je veux dire simplement
c'est qu'on n'est pas anti flics la
question c'est quelle police nous
voulons c'est un service public ne tenu
en échec comme le comme l'éducation
nationale on doit pouvoir critiquer la
police vous avez suivi les responsables
français cette année et non pas du tout
fondées vous êtes intéressé doit pouvoir
critiquer la police pour y compris
restaurer le lien avec la police c'est
pas critiquer c'est ce monsieur pommard
monsieur pour moi et c'est j'ai passé
mon visage je peux pas vous permettre de
dire des gens comme ça excuse est
moindre mais je vais essayer de dire ce
que je veux mais ouais mais parce que
vous connaissez pas la maison papules
sous votre main draw mais je n'ai jamais
été dans la police par contre vous avez
dit lorsque je mets pas les pieds dans
les quartiers la police ne s'est jamais
classé non mais je veux pas rentrer
dedans mais j'ai o'neill toutefois que
sur le suivant exigé c'est que non mais
j'aurais aussi loin il ya une jeunesse
qu'elle ait raison ou tort qui a un
rapport à la police qui est douloureux
et qui est compliquée et qui émaillé de
toute une série de témoignages c'est moi
qui serai pas vous le savez mais au
moins on restaure sa mégère exemple à
tanger vous
faire le débat non non on n'est pas là
pour le chan est sur les sujets c'est
sur l'autre mais entre en face à yen et
ben moi je crois que la baisse sous le
nom de scène et à la mélasse à supporter
avait été mon maman et ben moi j'ai car
elle a posé un débat est ce qu'il est et
il faut changer ça va glisser la région
et pour une fois c'est pas le sujet mais
vous trouvez qu'il a fait une bonne
émission sur les filles voient la
série s'arrête au delà le sujet c'est ça
ouais ce que vous arrivez la même chose
il est comme le commissaire mais non je
voulais être
historique on va pas refaire le débat
mais sur pardon comment l on ne laisse
qu'un discours anti flic est digne d'un
candidat à la présidence j'ai de la
rénover voilà la question je me suis
auto ies naulleau est ce que un discours
anti flics et adapté à la france entre
le raid été volé mais dans les deux
langues à jeudi non alors c'est ce que
j'ai entendu hier nationale nous
transférons trouver répondre à ma clause
écrite et moi ce que nous disons ça
n'est pas un discours anti phishing gaza
oui vous êtes très bien non les millions
de gens ont entendu la nappe choix je
vous réponds nous ne sont pas contre la
police il faut de la police il faut une
police républicaine avec des moyens il
faut un rapport restaurer leur niveau la
vis à la bonne franquette c'est vrai que
ça
allait dire ça même le policier n'a
reconnu que aujourd'hui la bac ne
fonctionne pas bien que la police de
proximité puissance sociaux fsss
et plus je vous fait
viable et
ça n'est pas si le sable regardez
regardez son image à vous montrer à la
presse leur apprennent que j'ai
rencontrés après les échanges avec le
policier regarde et jean luc mélenchon
en off ce qui demande à ses équipes
regardent
n'importe quoi sur les chiffres sur la
prise de plainte vous avez les chiffres
bien pas tant avec plaisir voilà
l'excusé pas recevoir prête pas d'accord
merci gagner
voilà c'est un peu ce que dit jean luc
mélenchon sera conduite sur le vaccin le
vaccin est une raquette troué et le pass
vaccinale et sont pourtant inefficaces
dirait qu'il a dix ans mais ça prouve
qu'il y voilà ouais c'était un très
mauvais
ça fait passer en direct c'est pareil
enfin
non mais s'il vous plaît il ça s'est
passé en direct c'est les gens qui l'ont
relevé mais moi je n'avais pas vu en
direct ces des gens qu'il revêt sur les
réseaux sociaux voilà il dit une demande
à siné kim qui trouvaient que j'étais un
peu trop féroce ses formes et sa ferme
moi je le reconnais mais ça mais non
mais je reconnais qu'à contre contention
opus moi je connais pas bien ce policier
mais je veux dire c'est un homme aussi
je les trouvais super il ne craint pas
la confrontation il a été formidable se
sont rentrés dedans et moi j'ai trouvé
qu'une fois qu'on a enlevé le bruit ce
qui l'est restée c'est une discussion
sur la police qui doit changer on a le
droit de dire la police ne doit pas
changer mais si on veut qu'elle change
selon ce que nous vous proposons avec
des moyens supplémentaires avec des
outils différents dirigeants lui plan
sur le compte et non mais j'ai eric
naulleau écoutez moi on n'est pas là
pour emmerder
c'est qu'on n'est pas là
pour ça que je vous dis que je suis
content que le débat ait lieu et puisque
et la gauche sur lequel je suis content
moi c'est la section à sofia tout via
oui c'est qu'ils étaient très émouvante
extrêmement dignes et qui pose aussi le
rapport de la population est comme vous
les palans prendre
toujours
2e mais il a toujours déterminant je
trouve qu'ils ont du rhin a été co même
si bien sûr mais ce que les attaquer moi
je trouve que c'est très très dangereux
ce discours qu'il a eue hier parce que
justement c'est dans l'émission de cyril
il sait qu'il va être écoutés et
regardés par nom par beaucoup beaucoup
de jeunes et se met trop l'accent tout
de suite sur les bavures policières sur
les yeux pleins de haine envers ce
policier ce que ce policier qui
représentait une institution de la
police en général
je suis désolée la dent
c'était la police eut désolé il avait
été et ne c'est une façon de séparer ce
qui est déjà difficile et les relations
entre les jeunes et les policiers sont
très compliqués c'était honteux parce
que je suis désolé c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent ça on peut pas lui enlever
et il sait ce qu'il fait et j'ai trouvé
ça justement vous avez parlé
d'association fia et elle est la une est
une présidentielle elle était digne elle
pourrait avoir dit la police la police a
demandé les propos du ministre suit des
libéraux pris l'eau j'étouffe pour dire
quand j'entends par les parieurs
j'étouffe
police en scandant mémoire et le
ministre il joue il fait une blague en
disant moi j'étouffe qui étaient les
propos du perche mais là ça leur a
répété mme giral ça devrait nous en
tirer